glaube wir müssen nämlich über die
politische intensivstationen fläche auf
der sich ihre partei gerade befindet und
zwar hat heute der erste kandidat der
erste cdu politiker seine kandidatur
verkündet für den parteivorsitz tja seit
september spricht die cdu über aufbruch
und heute wird der erste sein gut ins
rennen einer der wie kaum ein zweiter
für erneuerung steht und zwar der
kanzleramtsminister von angela merkel
helge braun das war natürlich ironie wer
erneuerung will kann natürlich
eigentlich nicht den kanzleramtsminister
von merkel wählen aber das ist gerade
die situation in der cdu noch hatte sich
kein anderer gemeldet kurz darauf hatte
dann vor wenigen stunden norbert röttgen
erklärt dass auch er jetzt wieder cdu
chef werden will also jemand der zum
zweiten mal machen will und jetzt wartet
die partei auf ihren basis liebling auf
den anderen auf hochs kandidaten
friedrich merz der vor 20 jahren schon
mal fraktionschef der schon zweimal
versucht hat
parteichef zu werden und er soll jetzt
auch noch sein gut in den ring werfen
und so soll erneuerung gelingt da frage
ich mich doch das ist in der cdu los
warum macht die nicht einmal auf rom
konnte denn niemand neues und sagt ich
mache ja bloß
also erstmal erstmals so kissel hat sich
mir gegenüber vor der sendung als kann
als lautern geoutet hat mich als hass
auf einmal leute findet ihr hier auf
erden ich habe ein bisschen mehr zu
lachen sonst nicht zum hsv ablehnt sich
otto rehhagel früherer kaiserslautern
trainer der einst gesagt es gibt nicht
junge oder alte spieler es gibt nur gute
spieler sondern ich glaube das muss auch
der maßstab sein für die cdu natürlich
brauchen wir auch in einigen positionen
eine verjüngung dass er völlig klar
haben wir auch alle gesagt also so als
er aber irgendwas aber es kann doch
jetzt nicht sein dass wir sagen jetzt
kommt aufs geschlecht an es kommt aus
alter an es kommt irgendwie auf die
region an sondern diejenigen die
kandidieren wollen sondern alle
gemeindlichen nrw die sich für die sich
für geeignetheit naja brown ist ja nicht
aus nrw ist nicht die sich für geeignet
halten die sollen kandidieren und dann
machen wir uns alle bild ich bin eines
von über 400.000 cdu mitgliedern und
dann wären wir alle abstimmen und dann
sehen was rauskommt das hat natürlich
trotzdem was komödiantisch ist also ich
habe als theaterregisseur gearbeitet und
ein stück das also so schnell von einer
tragödie in die absolute komödie über
gleitet habe ich noch nicht erlebt also
dieser quasi tragische absturz von armin
laschet an seinem eigenen lachen und
seiner überforderung gescheitert und
jetzt kommt wie kai aus der kiste der
master of disaster ältere frauen aus dem
bundeskanzleramt und wirft als erster
und das ist das wirklich demütigende
führt als erster seinen hut in den ring
das heißt man muss erst mal sagen
chapeau er traut sich wegst einer tritt
jemand an aber er wird es natürlich
nicht die cdu wieder mit dem klamauk und
gepudert wenn sie ausgerechnet helge
braun jetzt sozusagen an angela merkel
würde das haben sie vermutlich aber auch
schon zwei mal gesagt als annegret kramp
karrenbauer angetreten ist und als armin
laschet danke dadurch gemeinsamkeiten
aufweisen haben darauf dass sie sich in
zwei monaten aus aachen mit helge braun
als cdu-chef ich würde es der cdu nicht
mehr mitglied bin doch sonst wie aktien
habe einfach nicht raten weil es einfach
die fortsetzung wäre einer am ende mit
glückten kanzlerschaft und regentschaft
bin sagt auch mal alexander machen wir
eine eine runde wem würdest du denn
jetzt wie geben jetzt mein ratschlag der
union einer kann sie direkt mitbringen
in seiner parteizentrale reden würdest
du denn sagen wer sollte jetzt der neue
parteichef werden also ich find es mal
gut dass jetzt die basis gefragt werden
soll dass es nicht ausgeklügelt wenn es
jemand sagen ich würde sagen es wäre für
die partei von außen betrachtet am
besten wenn als übergangskandidat märz
es machen würde ja auf wen würdest du
tippen als realistisch haben einfach die
heute tatsächlich meine meinung sagen
ich ja ich sage kristina schröder sollte
es werden die ehemalige
familienministerin
eine hoch kompetente frau liberal und
konservativ wenn die cdu wirklich sich
überlegen würde wie sie wahlen gewinnen
will wie sie profil schärfen will dann
muss sie kristina schröder zurückholen
kristina schröder finde ich ehrlich bin
ja gerade auch ziemlich cool ich will
mich aber jetzt nicht einfach der schule
lang ja ich will mich ja auch immer
davon ab also sagt man selber man fühlt
sich im moment auch für eine kandidatur
geeignet will man das privat wenn man
das familiär sagt man ich möchte jetzt
genau auf die position also wenn man
cdu-chefin oder cdu-chef wird dann ist
das ja nicht so ein job das erste mal
nebenbei ich kann es ja mal versuchen da
muss man schon sehr stark auch in sich
gehen und prüfen bin ich dafür geeignet
man kriegt harte kritik von der bild bis
hin zu vielen anderen medien mann ist im
prinzip vom morgens bis abends inklusive
wochenende jederzeit rund um die uhr im
einsatz sondern deswegen muss jeder
kandidat jede kandidatin natürlich auch
sagen will ich das und nicht nur traue
ich mir das zu sondern passt das auch
zum familiären und privaten um war das
kann ein plädoyer für helge braun der
kann das ja als andere angestellt hat
ein crooner krise hinter sich also sie
sind für brown gericht heraus also ich
würde erstmal sagen wir schauen mal wer
alles am ende kandidiert das wissen wir
heute noch nicht es gibt ja
möglicherweise in den nächsten tagen
noch weitere kandidaturen wir haben ja
noch eine woche zeit dafür wen sind sie
denn ich werde jetzt erstmal alles
kandidiert dann wenn möglicherweise mich
äußern aber ich halte jetzt wenig davon
dass landesvorsitzende oder auch andere
mandatsträger bevor die frist der
kandidatur erklärung abgelaufen ist
jetzt schon sagen ja ich unterstützt den
oder den also schauen wir erst mal
wiederkommt und dann können wir uns auch
gegebenenfalls äußern wie wir menschen
spüren da hast du dich ja auch sein wen
findest du denn gut also ich finde
tatsächlich kassen will man sehr
interessant und sparen er hat eine weiße
weste und wirkt souverän hat substanz
und ist eben kein entertainer und das
finde ich dann welches also carsten
lindemann glaube ich muss eine ganz ganz
wichtige rolle spielen auch in der
künftigen cdu nur traurig anzutreten
oder also dafür müsste ihnen die sendung
einladen dann kann er selber zu
erklären ich muss ich kann deswegen
jetzt nur allgemein sagen weil ich will
jetzt ja auch nicht hier irgendwie
sprechen sagen die person muss
kandidieren nur sollte kandidieren die
person will das vielleicht gar nicht
also man muss ja selber auch seine
kandidatur wollen aber was ich sagen
kann ist carsten linnemann halte ich
auch für ganz ganz wichtig im künftigen
team der cdu die wahl herz ist wie man
war weil er meint dass man ein fan idol
jenem einheitskassen mann hat mehrere
vorzüge und vorteile einerseits glaube
ich spricht er viele enttäuschte ex cdu
wähler an oder potenziellen cdu-wähler
die wirtschaftsliberal die liberal
denkende oder auch konservativen denkens
setzt der und aber gleichzeitig später
auch von aufbruch und erneuerung und
auch wie ich finde auch in sehr engem
polizei nicht abgehoben ich kenne ihn ja
auch persönlich sehr gut es sehr
bodenständig mein schönes wort kein
entertainer substanz kann ich ja fand
also bei alles unterstreichen also hätte
ich nicht besser sagen können
lars lindemann ist schon mal sehr drin
aber witz denn jetzt mehr als das müssen
wir natürlich schon noch mal so alles ja
dass ich weiß über die spannende frage
wer wird das am ende also wieso will
muss erstmal ab wann wer alles
kandidiert und zweitens glaube ich kann
man das tatsächlich ganz ganz schwer
sagen weil es dürfen der über 400.000
cdu mitglieder abstimmen da werden viele
abstimmen die selbst landesvorsitzende
wie ich noch nie gesehen haben die sind
seit 30 40 jahren mit haben doch keine
chance doch
keiner keiner weiß doch wie alle cdu
mitglieder denken und gegner es gab ja
auch bei der spd am ende überraschung
hätte vorher niemand vermutet selbst die
spd-führung nicht und wir wissen nicht
was rauskommt dass das erste mal und
wieder ist wenn cdu mitglieder abstimmen
die seit 30 40 jahren dabei sind die man
aber noch nie bei irgendeiner
veranstaltung gesehen hat und was die
denken das weiß keiner genau ich glaube
bevor wir gleichen die sendung gehen
muss man einem ganz besonderen
cdu-mitglied erstmal herzlichen
glückwunsch wünschen ja alles gute zum
geburtstag zum 66 friedrich merz